so next paper is by Edward partner
Edward partner earned his doctorate in
art history from Indiana University and
currently serves as curator of
exhibitions for the mckissack Museum at
the University of South Carolina he has
received fellowships from Frederick
Douglass Institute at the University of
Rochester the luce foundation and the
Philadelphia Museum of Art net has also
worked at the Indiana University Art
Museum and the National Gallery of Art
in Washington DC his article winning the
piece over mr. prejudice Horace Pippin
and the social gospel and double V was
recently published in connection with
the exhibition Horace Pippin the way I
see it now on view and add the
Brandywine River Museum of Art his
research interests include
african-american art American modernism
contemporary art Falk self-taught
outsider art and the material culture of
American religions his paper today is
part of a largest study that will result
in an exhibition at the mckissack museum
next year Thank You tatianna thank you
to everyone organizing this conference
it's been really wonderful how do I
advance oh thank you in the immediate
aftermath of the Pearl Harbor attack two
of the largest African American
newspapers the Baltimore afro-american
and the Chicago Defender each each
published editorial cartoon showing
public response to the attack and to the
country's entry into World War two on
the Left we see an upright citizen
eagerly offering a service to President
Roosevelt in his Joint Chiefs who each
look up from their war plans entitled
how to lick Japan with broad shoulders
and a rigid stance the central figures
to loot communicates loyalty and a sense
of duty among readers of the African
American press on the right we encounter
Uncle Sam standing on a pulpit loosely
fitted with a preacher's robe and
awkward phony halo preaching to
opposition leaders of the Axis forces
startled by a bottle that slips from his
pocket labeled racial intolerance
exploitation 165 years old Uncle Sam
mutters don't do as I do do as I say as
he reveals the embarrassing liquor that
undermines his words and sends a chuckle
through his audience embodying both
pessimism and scorn on the one hand and
hope enthusiasm and courage on the other
these two cartoons display the sharp
contrast of opinion is shared by many
African Americans as they confronted the
new reality and consequences of
America's imminent fight for democracy
abroad these two cartoons raise broader
questions about how editorial cartoons
complimented larger dialogic shifts in
the wartime media as mass produce images
released weekly to millions of readers
newspaper cartoons reflected and shaped
popular opinion they afforded singular
images that summed up new messaging new
policy and new scent and new sentiments
forging a rich unified site a political
awareness and engagement for African
Americans across the nation the
following study tracks the modes by
which cartoons of the African American
press navigated a sensitive balance at
play within the press between a militant
voice struggling for racial justice and
an outwardly patriotic image of action
pushing up against threats of government
sanction it surveys cartoons within the
defender and the afro-american over the
wars first year revealing an effort to
forge a new image of a modern afro Mara
african-american overcoming the lean
Depression years with great increases in
circulation the combined newspapers of
the Black Press reached over a million
readers nationwide by 1940 becoming one
of the leading african-american run
industries and the figures are that in
1940 there were 100 1.2 million
subscribers with a secondary readership
of close to six million as those are
estimates and that increased to 1.8
million by 1945 with this increase
editor's for many large syndicated
newspaper has modified their messaging
with the onset of the war effort to
match reader interests for example
scholars note that
much of the crime related news that had
previously dominated the peacetime press
was steadily eliminated to make space
for an important new emphasis stories of
black troops and their role in the
services newspapers also brought in more
columnist representing an enormous range
of interests and philosophies from
conservative too radical these strategic
changes were a coordinated effort aimed
at not only stimulating sales but also
to give to giving voice to emerging
audiences that were increasingly urban
literate and militant the centrality of
the African American soldier within
these cartoons is not surprising as
David cario writes the meaning and
content of cartoons and comics quote is
determined not by the artist but by the
audience reflecting the fantasies of its
public end quote the soldier was an
effective public image for pointing to
the country's military it's fight for
democracy and in this case its racial
iniquities in these cartoons men and
women were assigned with almost endless
potential encouraged by the belief that
each of them could disrupt assume
notions of inferiority rampant with in
every sector of the war industry at the
time the soldier image mediated a desire
for a new afro-american African American
hero doing so by accomplishing three
tasks first it allowed cartoonists to
render a variety of race issues on an
individual scale making them more
readable and giving voice to those
people oppressed by them second it
presented a dual image at once positive
patriotic cleverly protesting
institutionalized discrimination in the
military and engaging otherwise lukewarm
attitudes that many african-americans
had for the war and third it functioned
to advance representation the
representation of African Americans
instilling a self-image as a modern
soldier or modern American replacing
derogatory stereotypical characters by
whites from decades past a cartoon in
the Baltimore afro-american from January
thirteenth 1942 offers a good starting
point quoting heavily from Rodin's
thinker the cartoonist centers the image
on the Africa
Americans capacity for knowledge a
static figure this black draftee helps
convey the sage hopeful advice of its
adjacent opinion column quote America
needs all the trained men she can get
whatever difficulties there may be there
may be in getting into the armed
services into industry and manufacturing
today these will not exist tomorrow any
bright young man can get ahead if he
will fight his way into and through the
defense schools to a skill to trade if
he will stay out of the bright night
spots and burn the midnight oil instead
this is where the dividends are for the
duration the strong and well-prepared
will be pushed ahead end quote the
column lays out an almost inevitable
future clinging tightly to the American
dream work hard get pushed ahead yet key
to this success is the phrase if you
fight your way the column in cartoon
make direct calls for eligible men and
women to insist upon receiving training
and work past the threats of Jim Crow
Jay Jackson's cartoon still not too late
to cut his bonds in the Chicago Defender
from the same week takes a different
approach to the same point here the
biblical tale of Samson and Delilah
becomes transposed onto the battle for
racial parity with in all branches of
the military garb dance abducted in a
seductive draft dress in Stars and
Stripes that would make Uncle Sam's head
spin Delilah cut Samson's braids binds
his arms and wakes him just as the
philistines are upon them Samson is
astonished to witnesses vulnerability
with clues superimposed onto the shore
and hair and restraints the cartoon
image gives meaning to the helplessness
felt by millions of African American
recruits who were passed over by the
draft in the opening months of the war
later in January later in January the
defender cartoon black man to die in the
Navy pays tribute to Dorie Miller the
Afro african-american messmann who went
above and beyond his duties during the
Pearl Harbor attack Miller's name had
not been released by this time and so
his vague floating image remains a hazy
personage Bay's bathed in light yet he
is balanced with a seemingly dramatic
train
for a relief relief funds below from
champion boxer and newly minted recruit
Joe Lewis to the US Navy the pairing
takes up the frustration of the week's
editorials as one writer laments quote
Negroes by the thousands are buying
defense savings bonds and stamps despite
this our government remains unchanged in
its policy of segregation end quote
elsewhere another protests the refusal
of black youth by recruiting offices
asking methodically quote does the
government want the Negro in this war
end quote however the cartoon appears to
resolve the protests suggesting that
Dory Miller's inspirational story gave
meaning to the donation of African
American aid even with the refusals
African Americans faced at the
recruiting offices the best and the
brightest of the race were donating to
the war effort as a result a new iconic
image a hazy paradigm was sure to emerge
another defender cartoon an early
februari entitled can't see the good for
the blob broadens our perspective beyond
America's borders a North African
fighter stands in front of an oversized
leaflet plotted with an ink stain that
reads American and British race
prejudice echoing the week's polemic
against a pan pan american diplomatic
recommendation pushing south american
republics to cut ties with the Axis
powers the cartoon offers a disparaging
perspective on attitudes attitudes
towards the u.s. what one columnist
characterized as quote and attitude
brought about by America's unpalatable
racial superiority as manifested in the
outrageous treatment of her black
minority a treatment scarcely
distinguishable from that of Jewish
minorities in the Hitler dominated
countries end quote no longer focused on
racial discrimination on the homefront
the editorial looks outward the
selection of a soldier here helps drive
home the inimical effects of American
and British discrimination but also
alludes to the idea that the dual
American struggles to save democracy
abroad and to battle racism on the home
at home are not unique other powerful
allies other soldiers of color the world
over may be considering the peace aims
of the Allied forces weighing the
consequences
of choosing sides with profound
skepticism two weeks later in the end of
februari the defender published
transfusion needed the sooner the better
rendering a timely image focused
squarely on the discriminatory policies
of the Red Cross that barred
african-americans from donating blood to
the war effort the organization had just
changed its policy accepting
african-american blood but keeping it
segregated for many this plan only
fueled resentment for the war effort
with its tiny subtitles the cartoon
expands the focus away from this lesser
issue to more significant meetings at
play the profound need for more
african-americans in all branches of us
defense efforts it presents a clean
uncomplicated image with a white nurse
administering the process a healthy
african-american natural-born worker and
fighter smiles calmly as his blood is
drawn and transferred directly to a week
emaciated white man the forbidden
transfusion is removed from time in
place no visual cues tell us the cause
for the illness no frontline location is
given we simply witnessed a donation of
african-american might to the war over
the first two months of 1942 J Jackson
and the syndicated cartoonist of the
Africa afro-american remained consistent
in their use of male heroic figures like
these these cartoons show limitless
potential for action a seeming
righteousness a selflessness and a
generosity of spirit that are matched
only by the government's ability to deny
training J Jackson wilbert Holloway
Francis Yancy George Mercer Sims
Campbell Oliver Harrington and many
cartoonists working for the press at
this time consciously selected
structured and captioned their soldier
in this soldier image doing so with
details that in truth rose above the
message of the editorials their work
both in cartoons and comic strips
expanded the possibilities of cartoon
imagery more generally to combat
negative stereotyping of African
Americans Oliver Harrington who
contributed comic strips and was likely
the cartoonists behind some of the
African afro-american cartoons seen here
a test to specifically defining his
figures in reaction to the draw
tori imagery of decades earlier like the
examples seen here he stated quote black
faces were always represented as a
circle black with two hot dogs in the
middle for a mouth the black figure and
my cartooning it was a conscious effort
on my part to change that the black had
to disappear the rubber lips had to
disappear end quote Harrington's urgent
need to counteract negative imagery and
eradicate the black and the lips stems
from what Michael Harris identifies as a
conceptual and corporate incarceration
he writes quote the derogatory and
servitor typical imagery found in 19th
century minstrel performance and popular
media combined with political social and
economic oppression and the official and
renegade enforcement of racial ideology
to control and trap the black individual
within his or her community and
ultimately within his or her body and
quote Harrington Jackson and others
clearly utilized their cartoons to break
free of this control in the page of the
African American press there is a rather
consistent focus on the figure
aggressively pinpointing and acting and
acting against this history Harrington
in particular states that he turned to
the work of Milton Kenneth at this time
whose action-adventure comic strip Terry
and the Pirates set new standards of
comic art with its authentic highly
detailed backgrounds and dramatically
stage figures the effort to reinvent to
re-image the figure was not unique to
cartoonists though by 1940 large
circulation newspapers like the
afro-american the defender and the
Pittsburgh courier shared images of and
information about african-americans for
african-americans in a variety of
positive ways advertisements for example
guided readers through society
suggesting where to shop with without
humiliation or where to apply for a job
that would not discriminate newspapers
also included sports and society pages
praising athletes and professionals
otherwise ignored by the white press
many of the larger papers also formally
organized in 1940 creating the National
Negro publishers association or NNPA a
vitally important coalition of editors
the nnpa facilitated a you know
viewpoint and coordinated policies among
the country's largest papers within
three months after the war the start of
World War two they also adopted a war
resolution pledging to collectively
campaigned for victory at home and
abroad this this morphed into unique yet
aligned campaigns the double V campaign
initiated by the Pittsburgh courier and
the Baltimore afro-american and the
defenders remember Pearl Harbor and
sikeston to generating national debate
they advocated participation in the war
and an equal protest against racism and
discrimination on the homefront the
Chicago defenders campaign linked the
Pearl Harbor attack with a horrific
lynching in Sikeston Missouri that
occurred in January 1942 itself a
recurrent theme in the wartime press
well aware that these campaigns would
unquestionably foretell clashes with the
government the coalition of the nnpa
offered each newspaper a level of
confidence through a vast organizational
network of partnerships colonists of the
white press immediately labeled the
Black Press and organ of protest black
editor is in turn reverted the white
response to their audience saying quote
to the Negro and his press alike the
efforts of a large section of white
America to check his protest rather than
examine and act upon its causes seemed
utterly at variance with the avowed
Democratic objectives of the present
world struggle end quote those
skillfully designed to spur debate such
statements agitated government agencies
one historian writes quote it became
increasingly clear to many editors just
how seriously their position with the
government had deteriorated when scare
words such as suppression and sedition
charges began to filter into the
newspaper offices end quote six
different agencies from the FBI to the
post office began investigations into
various African American newspapers in
early nineteen forty two editors of the
Black Press and civic leaders were asked
to meet with the FBI about the
popularity of their campaigns and the
threat to african-american morale those
some scholars note that these meetings
only solidified the racial militancy of
the press others reveal a more positive
outcome historians Charles Simmons and
Patrick Washburn refer to these meetings
as actually for stalling more excessive
levels of militancy Simmons writes quote
despite the militant front originally
presented by editors government
officials were so persuasive with their
talks that some editors decided to take
another look at their editorial
philosophies and agreed to approach new
opinions with some caution end quote
while it is unclear which editors soften
their stance or how their influence made
its way through the NNPA aspects of this
modified approach seem to inflict the
cartoons that followed innate and
notable ways within the first three
issues of the Chicago Defender in March
oops the wrong way within the first
three issues of the Chicago Defender in
march of 1942 we see action no longer
dwelling on giving blood or insisting on
training the new African American
soldier here exemplifies engagement
readiness and loyalty in alienating the
affections of his strongest ally in the
upper-left corner for example a hulking
oversized african-american figure
representing the combined strength of
the world's colored races and sympathies
rises up breaking is changed with chains
with a clenched fist as he turns his
attention to the miniscule race baiter
brandished brandishing a sword in his
opposite hand behind the massive form
another tiny avatar of Nazism quips I
hope they never get together and team up
team up on me and the defenders so sorry
please at the bottom from a week later a
black GI newly arrived in Australia
grits his teeth and crouches next to a
sign proclaiming no colored races
allowed his grimace and tight grip on
the trigger a signal of fierce anger and
defiance that appears as directed at the
sign as it is on on it's not the enemy
even so he appears to trudge on to
battle
the following weeks cartoon she
delivered me and I will deliver her on
the upper right shows lady democracy
under siege her home in the background
now in flames democracy is held in a
stranglehold by a wide-eyed Nazi Nazi
officer glowering as he shouts loose me
a stern powerful african-american man
rolls up his sleeve about to wallop the
forces of rage race prejudice that keep
him from saving her a short essay
accompanies this scene with the ending
quote mr. president if you have an
answer for Japan Italy in Germany here
are those who will speed it to them
speed it in tracks of blood with hearts
as loyal as unyielding faith here they
are mr. president ready eager loyal true
as the stars end quote featuring the
heightened drama of action adventure
comic strips the cartons the cartoon
seems to unleash the African American
soldier portraying him as the only hope
for democracy presenting action loyalty
and change other subsequent cartoons
suggest that women complete this hopeful
hopeful patriotic galvanizing image too
invoking notables Sojourner Truth and
Harriet Beecher Stowe the image on the
right carries an editorial with the
decrees quote so they are ready eager
for Wars alarms its suffering and
sacrifices ready or than thousands of
brothers as ready as any women called by
the Union to the colors of freedom end
quote by contrast the cartoon on the
Left offers Frank comment on the
politically engaged domestic burdened
with the mundane others like back to
defense makes dinging attacks on the
unfortunate politics behind the Women's
Auxiliary corps that undermined efforts
to attract african-american recruits the
recruits themselves are model citizens
though loyal to the flag and insistently
walking past barriers to return to David
carriers phrase we see fantasies of the
public emerging here as a quick survey
of later cartoons from 1942 illustrate
whether acknowledging new policy changes
questioning the very nature of victory
or dramatizing the historical moment
through comedic trope
the soldier humanized abstract comments
at work within Jim Crow society and the
government military complex he or she
also iterated a mental image for
millions of readers of what action and
loyalty looked like forming positive
encouraging models that function to spur
debate boost morale and temper excessive
militancy cartoons like these reflect
the complexity of the african-american
experience during World War two they
alternate between a true hero or shining
example and its opposite lashing out
against preconceived notions of
patriotism yet also enriching them the
new soldiers here are historical
correctives disruptive agents of voice
in action representing unique amalgams
of loyalty to American democracy in
protest and protest against the morally
wrong elements within it in truth both
sides of the subtle dualism remained
crucial cartoonists had to appease both
conservative and militant factions and
reassure government agencies that they
would keep up morale for the war by
keeping the public fantasy of an African
American soldier fresh in the minds of
readers week after week cartoonists did
both humor is a historical cultural
product changing as social mores and
lifestyle shift to keep up with a modern
world as a public locus of humor these
cartoons helped breeders identify with a
new image a modern soldier and mediate
strong feelings about the needs fears
and identities identity of communities
nationwide each cartoon thus occupies a
somewhat reflexive function one built
off of reader response filtered by an
editor and interpreted by an artist from
source to message to cultural product as
we begin to reconstruct the humor of
this era the emergence of this hero
confirms new elements of the
african-american experience fighting for
country fighting for rights turning away
from the past and fighting for a better
future thank
you